la parole est maintenant monsieur à la
marque pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire vous avez la parole
mon cher collègue merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur qui a répondu
d'ailleurs en partie à un précédent
collègues sur le même sujet monsieur le
ministre l'aveyron a connu au même titre
que d'autres départements du sud de la
france les rhône le var et les
pyrénées-orientales des intempéries
d'une violence inouïe il ya quelques
jours je tiens à saluer ici la
mobilisation exceptionnelle des secours
pompiers gendarmes policiers mais aussi
la qualité de l'action des bénévoles qui
par solidarité et avec efficacité sont
intervenus auprès des sinistrés la ville
de saint-affrique par exemple a subi des
inondations catastrophiques d'une
importance jamais connu dans l'histoire
de celle ci qui a neuf mille habitants
vous avez été très réactifs sur le
ministre en prenant quelques arrêtés de
catastrophe naturelle pour que les biens
assurés bénéficient de cette procédure
et je vous en remercie au nom des
populations concernées toutefois
toutefois nous apprenons ce matin que
dix communes de l'aveyron je vais
rapidement les cités coupiac tournemire
c'est en décernant la bastide pradines
brousse-le-château combrée lapanouse de
cernon martrin saint beauzély
saint-juéry n'ont pas bénéficié de
l'arrêté de catastrophe naturelle à ce
jour je sais que vous allez faire le
maximum monsieur le ministre pour que
soit résolu ses problèmes qui
apparemment sont d'ordre technocratique
le plus rapidement possible nous ne
comprendrions pas en effet que ces
communes qui ont subi des dégâts très
conséquent ne soit pas retenu attendons
une réponse de votre part sur ce sujet
pour ce qui est des biens non assurables
des collectivités locales touchées par
ces intempéries les dégâts se chiffrent
pour un département comme le mien comme
l'aviron à plusieurs millions d'euros il
s'agit du patrimoine routier les
chaussées les pommes 3,4 millions
d'euros pour le seul conseil général de
l'aveyron mais aussi des stades et bien
d'autres infrastructures pour les
communes et communautés de communes
monsieur le ministre nous en appelons à
la solidarité nationale que ce soit à
travers le fond de solidarité ou
peut-être la detr vous avez récemment
annoncé avant les intempéries une
augmentation sensible de ce fonds au
niveau national l'urgence et la gravité
de la situation pourrait-elle permettre
que cette augmentation nationale soit
fléchier vers les départements que le
plus souffert de ces événements
climatiques d'une grande violence même
s'il ce n'est pas la vocation initiale
de ce fonds mais pour me répondre la
parole comme chez bernard cazeneuve
ministre de l'intérieur devait la parole
mutu 2010 oui monsieur le sénateur
m'interrogeais sur les inondations et
les intempéries qui ont eu lieu dans
l'aveyron avec certaines communes qui
ont été particulièrement touchés je
pense notamment à la commune de
saint-affrique dont venait de parler
l'instant j'ai souhaité que
au conseil des miss qui a suivi
immédiatement ces intempéries on puisse
prendre l'arrêté catastrophes naturelles
de manière à ce que l'indemnisation des
collectivités concernées puissent être
effective dans des délais brefs mais
vous avez raison de dire que cet arrêté
catastrophes naturelles a permis à 23
communes de pouvoir être inscrite comme
susceptibles d'être indemnisées qu'il en
reste encore quelques unes qui n'ont pas
été retenus j'ai indiqué à certains de
vos élus que dans les dix jours qui
viennent il pourra être procédé à un
examen attentif de la situation de ces
communes de manière à ce qu'aucune qui a
été victimes de ces intempéries ne soit
laissé sur le bord du chemin et nous
devons faire en sorte sur les 23
communes de l'aveyron plus celle la
dizaine qui reste encore en cours comme
sur les 178 commune des autres
départements qui sont concernés par ces
arrêter de faire en sorte que les
financements interviennent rapidement
poser une deuxième question qui est
celle de la dotation d'équipement des
territoires ruraux dont le premier
ministre a annoncé qu'elle sera
augmentait de assez significativement
pour 2015 et vous me posez la question
de savoir si on peut affecter cette
dotation aux collectivités locales qui
ont fait l'objet d'intempéries il ya
deux éléments de réponse à cela premier
élément de réponse il appartient aux
préfets en liaison avec les
collectivités territoriales de
déterminer les conditions d'allocation
de ces fonds dans la plus grande
concertation avec les élus c'est le sens
d instruction que je leur ai donné plus
particulièrement dans les départements
touchés par les inondations
et deuxièmement il est souhaitable et
possible de cumuler la dotation
d'équipement des territoires ruraux avec
le fond calamités et le fond catastrophe
naturelle dans une limite de 80 % de
taux de subvention pour les
collectivités locales concernées voilà
donc quelles sont les règles vous pouvez
constater qu'elles permettent
une concertation avec les collectivités
une indemnisation de bonnes conditions à
cela s'ajoutera les mesures que j'ai
annoncé tout à l'heure à votre collègue
collombat c'est à dire une réforme du
processus catastrophe naturelle car ça
ne sert à rien de passer rapidement les
arrêter en conseil des ministres si
l'otan après les arrêter est aussi
significatif que celui qui existait
avant le procédure accélérée ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire fusionner les
font des avances augmenté des
inspections plus simple et un niveau
d'avant ce plus significatif pour
permettre aux collectivités locales
d'être indemnisé avant même la
présentation des factures pour celles
qui sont les plus affectés par ces
catastrophes naturelles merci